Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishist terror, murder and bloodshed. But they produced Michelangelo, Leonardo da Vinci and the Renaissance. In Switzerland, they had brotherly love. They had 500 years of democracy and peace. And what did that produce? The cuckoo clock.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishist 恐怖、谋杀和流血事件。但他们孕育了米开朗琪罗、列奥纳多·达·芬奇和文艺复兴。在瑞士，他们有兄弟般的爱。他们有500年的民主与和平。这带来了什么？布谷鸟钟。
That was Orson Welles as Harry Lyme in The Third Man. A famous description of civilisation and with its focus on the Renaissance as a time of terror, but also of stupefying artistic achievement. It channels kind of, you know, a slightly complex idea of the golden age dominic which is going to be our i don't think they do make cuckoo clocks today by the way i think they make them in the black forest in germany um that's correct so they do they do orson welles got called up so harry lime or to apologize because of course orson welles
那是奥逊·威尔斯在《第三人》中饰演的哈里·莱姆。这是对文明的著名描述，它将文艺复兴视为一个充满恐怖的时期，但同时也取得了令人目眩神迷的艺术成就。它带有一种，你知道的，关于黄金时代的稍微复杂的概念，多米尼克，这将是我们的……顺便说一句，我不认为他们今天还在制造布谷鸟钟，我想他们是在德国的黑森林里制造的，嗯，没错，所以他们确实……奥逊·威尔斯被叫去，所以哈里·莱姆或者去道歉，因为当然，奥逊·威尔斯
wrote that graham green didn't write that he wrote the film but orson welles. You had to apologise. Because, of course, Orson Welles wrote that. Graham Greene didn't write that. He wrote the film, but Orson Welles wrote that speech. And, of course, The Third Man is itself the product of what people might see as a golden age of cinema, now defunct in the age of Marvel films and so on. So, yes, golden ages, it's a funny topic because it seems quite amorphous, but we all know what we mean. We all know, we all have a sense.
写了那段话，格雷厄姆·格林没有写。他写了这部电影，但是奥逊·威尔斯。你不得不道歉。因为，当然，奥逊·威尔斯写了那段话。格雷厄姆·格林没有写。他写了这部电影，但奥逊·威尔斯写了那段演讲。而且，当然，电影《第三人》本身就是人们可能视为电影黄金时代的产物，在漫威电影等层出不穷的今天，这个时代已经不复存在了。所以，是的，黄金时代，这是一个有趣的话题，因为它看起来相当模糊，但我们都知道我们指的是什么。我们都懂，我们都有这种感觉。
Well, do we? Do we? Because Faramir Zayn has asked, what makes a golden age a golden age? And conversely, Diogo Morgado, the only man in the world more left-wing than you, Dominic. Is that by his own description? No, he's just a parent. I mean, he's very, very, he is asking, isn't the whole concept of golden ages incredibly outdated?
真的吗？真的是这样吗？因为法拉米尔·扎因（Faramir Zayn）问过：是什么让黄金时代成为黄金时代？反过来说，迪奥戈·莫尔加多（Diogo Morgado）是世界上唯一一个比你更左翼的人，多米尼克。这是他自己的描述吗？不，他只是个家长。我的意思是，他非常、非常……他在问，难道黄金时代这个整个概念不是极其过时的吗？
Like the great man theory, the study of history has advanced beyond golden or dark ages to a much more interesting palette of infinite greys. So he's an Orson Welles man. Because, I mean, he does have, I mean, there are greys in that Orson Welles description. I think Orson Welles is saying that the Renaissance was Golden Age. It's just that the context for the Golden Age is violence. Yes, okay, fine. But you might say that a Golden Age is a Golden Age that's a cultural effervescence,
就像伟大人物理论一样，历史研究已经超越了黄金时代或黑暗时代，进入了一个更加有趣的无限灰色地带。所以他是个奥逊·威尔斯式的人物。因为，我的意思是，他确实有——奥逊·威尔斯的那个描述中确实存在灰色地带。我认为奥逊·威尔斯的意思是文艺复兴是一个黄金时代。只是黄金时代的背景是暴力。是的，好吧，没问题。但你可能会说，黄金时代是一个充满文化生机、
but is also economically prosperous. Yeah, though the two usually go hand in hand, I would say. Dutch Golden Age, Spanish Golden Age. The Renaissance is the classic counterpoint to that. So, Dominic, what do you think? What makes a golden age a gold? And is it legitimate to talk about golden ages? Yes. So what makes a golden age a golden age? It's all retrospective, isn't it? It's a sense of loss, a sense of nostalgia. So in a funny way, what makes a golden age a golden age is nothing necessarily to do with the age itself, but the age that follows it.
同时又经济繁荣的时代。是的，尽管这两者通常是相辅相成的，我想说。荷兰黄金时代，西班牙黄金时代。文艺复兴是这方面的经典反例。那么，多米尼克，你怎么看？是什么让一个黄金时代成为金……谈论黄金时代合理吗？是的。那么，是什么让一个黄金时代成为黄金时代呢？这都是回顾性的，不是吗？是一种失落感，一种怀旧之情。所以有趣的是，造就黄金时代的与其说是时代本身，不如说是紧随其后的那个时代。
So in other words, the age that puts it on the pedestal. So you need a sense of, so it's not that the whole concept of golden ages is not just about yesterday. It's also about today. So in other words, what makes it golden? So you can't have a golden age without an iron age. You can't have a 1960s without a 1970s, maybe, put it that way. And I think, as for the second question, so that would be what makes the Golden Age.
换句话说，是那个把它奉上神坛的时代。所以你需要一种……因此，黄金时代这个概念不仅仅是关于昨天的。它也关乎今天。换句话说，是什么让它成为金色的？所以，没有铁器时代，就不会有黄金时代。或许可以这样说，没有20世纪70年代，就不会有20世纪60年代。我想，至于第二个问题，那将是造就黄金时代的原因。
It's perceived as a period of affluence or a period of success that's followed by one of disappointment. It's the kind of party and then the hangover. And the second point, you know, is it outdated i mean i'm sure historians academic historians would absolutely go along with this i mean i think if you sat in a university research seminar and talked about the golden golden age of this or that you know there'd be all sorts of disapproving looks and frowns and stuff but obviously it's i think it's it's hardwired into our kind of imagination,
它被视为一个富裕或成功的时期，随后是一个令人失望的时期。这就像是一场派对，接着就是宿醉。至于第二点，你知道，它过时了吗？我的意思是，我确信历史学家、学术历史学家绝对会同意这一点。我的意思是，如果你坐在大学的研究研讨会上，谈论这个或那个的黄金时代，你知道的，会有各种不赞成的眼神和皱眉之类的事情，但很显然，我认为这已经深深烙印在我们的想象力中，
our historical imagination, isn't it? That we think about the golden age of Athens, the golden age of Elizabethan England, the golden age of... And also politically, political parties generally trade in golden ages. So the Tories have a sense of when Britain was great. Labour has a sense of when Britain was compassionate. And everything has been downhill since then. I think that's part of any modern political movement's appeal. Isn't the anxiety around golden ages expressive of two things? One of which is the idea that, say, certain great works of literature or art or whatever can be said to be greater than those of other periods yeah and also that um the idea that it's somehow uh chauvinist to say that um a certain place
我们的历史想象力中，不是吗？我们想到雅典的黄金时代，伊丽莎白时代的英格兰的黄金时代，……的黄金时代。而且在政治上，政党通常也以黄金时代为卖点。因此，保守党对英国何时伟大有一种感觉。工党对英国何时富有同情心有一种感觉。自那以后，一切都在走下坡路。我认为这是任何现代政治运动吸引力的一部分。难道围绕黄金时代的焦虑表达了两件事吗？其中之一就是这样的观点：比如说，某些伟大的文学或艺术作品等等，可以被称为比其他时期的作品更伟大，是的，还有……这种观点，即认为说某个地方
has a particular golden age and what about the other places um how are you measuring the golden age yeah sort of it's that classic distrust. Well, it's also that slight academic distrust of basically saying anything at all. Well, I think of saying that certain things were kind of better than other things. There's a real anxiety about that. Yeah, that's absolutely right. I completely agree with that. They're not better or worse.
拥有一个特定的黄金时代在某种程度上是沙文主义的，那么其他地方呢……你是如何衡量黄金时代的？是的，这有点那种经典的怀疑态度。嗯，这也是那种轻微的学术怀疑态度，基本上什么都不敢说。嗯，我认为是说某些事情在某种程度上比其他事情更好。对此存在真正的焦虑。是的，完全正确。我完全同意这一点。它们没有更好或更糟。
They're just different. That's the sort of the mantra, isn't it? Yeah, it's Bob Dylan and Keats. Well, obviously, Keats is better than bob dylan i mean everyone knows that um because dominic you said you said um that golden ages are defined by ages that come after them yeah by and large by and large you're gonna now annoy me with an exception. I can just see it coming. Okay. So, yeah, there's a question from Max Parker. What would be the shortest gap between the Golden Age itself
它们只是不同。这就是那种口号，不是吗？是的，这就是鲍勃·迪伦和济慈。好吧，很明显，济慈比鲍勃·迪伦更好，我的意思是每个人都知道这一点……因为多米尼克，你说过，你曾说过……黄金时代是由紧随其后的时代所定义的。是的，大体上是这样。大体上，你现在要用一个例外来惹恼我了。我能预料到。好吧。所以，是的，马克斯·帕克（Max Parker）有一个问题。黄金时代本身与
and it being referred to as such? So I would say in the Western imagination, the founding idea of Golden Ages are Periclean athens yeah and august and rome so those are the those those are basically for people in the west those are the two pinnacles and so when you know we had mary beard talking about classics when you study classics the focus tends to be on the great writers of of athens and of Augustan Rome. And it was an important part of the mythology of both those periods
被称为黄金时代之间最短的间隔会是多久？所以我想说，在西方人的想象中，黄金时代的奠基理念是伯利克里时期的雅典，是的，还有奥古斯都时期的罗马。所以，这些就是……对于西方人来说，这是两个巅峰。所以当……你知道，我们曾请玛丽·比尔德（Mary Beard）来谈论古典学时，当你学习古典学时，重点往往放在雅典和奥古斯都时期罗马的伟大作家身上。这是这两个时期神话的重要组成部分，
that they were living through golden ages. So Pericles gives a funeral speech in the second year of the Peloponnesian War. Spartans have been at the gates. And he says, basically, we're brilliant. Athens is great. We're the school, you know, we are the school for Greece. Yeah, we are the best. And I would say that to Max Parker's question, I mean, the golden age has already ended in a sense when Pericles says that, because very soon, great plague is going to hit Athens.
即他们正生活在黄金时代。因此，伯利克里在伯罗奔尼撒战争的第二年发表了一场葬礼演说。斯巴达人已经兵临城下。他说，基本上，我们很出色。雅典很伟大。我们是学校，你知道的，我们是希腊的学校。是的，我们是最好的。我想说，对于马克斯·帕克的问题，我的意思是，从某种意义上说，当伯利克里说出这番话时，黄金时代已经结束了，因为很快，一场大瘟疫就将袭击雅典。
Pericles is going to die of it and the Periclean age is going to come to an end i mean obviously the genius of you know are we allowed to talk about genius i suppose kind of uh but you've got you've still got socrates and plato and the tragedians and aristophanes to come they're still floating around but it is a horrible age of plague and war so perhaps to that extent the myth the mythologization is going on and and with augustus you've got um this famous fourth eclogue written by Virgil before Augustus becomes Augustus even. I mean, kind of when there's still a civil war going on. And he has this kind of famous description of a new cycle, bread of time beginning again, and justice and a golden age. He says the golden age returns, and he describes the birth of a child a baby boy the generation of iron will pass a generation of gold will inherit all the world and the romans interpreted that as meaning
伯利克里将死于这场瘟疫，伯利克里时代即将走向终结。我的意思是，很明显，……的天才（我们被允许谈论天才吗？我想可以吧，呃……），但你仍然有苏格拉底、柏拉图、悲剧作家和阿里斯托芬等着你，他们仍然在活跃，但这是一个充满瘟疫和战争的糟糕时代。因此，在某种程度上，神话化正在发生。在奥古斯都时期，你有……维吉尔在奥古斯都甚至成为奥古斯都之前写下的这首著名的《第四牧歌》。我的意思是，当时内战还在继续。他用这种著名的方式描述了一个新的循环，时间的面包重新开始，正义和黄金时代。他说黄金时代重现，并描述了一个孩子的诞生，一个男婴，铁的世代将过去，金的世代将继承全世界，罗马人将其解读为这意味着
that this great golden age of of augustus yeah although of course in due course christians gave it a different spin but if we can unpick both of those so first of all periclean athens are people at the time aware do they think of themselves as living through a golden age and what was your answer so yes they do they do and to people immediately afterwards so in athens after the death of pericles after the death of socrates and so on do they think do they look back and say that was a golden age and it's been downhill since then so the golden age of pericles is when athens is at peace it's strong it's building the parthenon and so on and then the peloponnesian war presumably and then the peloponnesian war begins and i think i mean if you look at thucydides who's
奥古斯都的这个伟大黄金时代，是的，尽管当然，基督徒在适当的时候赋予了它不同的解读。但如果我们能剖析这两者：首先是伯利克里时期的雅典，当时的民众是否有意识，他们是否认为自己正生活在黄金时代？你的回答是什么？是的，他们确实这么认为。对于紧随其后的人来说，在伯利克里死后、苏格拉底死后的雅典等等，他们是否会回首过去并说那是一个黄金时代，而自那以后一切都在走下坡路？因此，伯利克里的黄金时代是雅典处于和平、强大、正在建造帕台农神庙等时期的阶段，然后是伯罗奔尼撒战争，想必……然后伯罗奔尼撒战争开始了。我想，如果你看看修昔底德，他
our chief you know who gives us the funeral speech uh his book is a set you know his history is essentially an account of how over-optimism, based on a sense that they were living through a golden age, is what dragged Athens into what becomes decades of war and ultimately defeat. Hubris and nemesis. I mean, that often lies at the heart of all golden ages, doesn't it? The idea that doom and disaster are coming. You're in the middle of the party, but the hangover is looming.
是我们主要的……（他为我们提供了葬礼演说），他的书是一套……（他的历史本质上是一个账户），讲述了基于他们生活在黄金时代的感觉而产生的过度乐观情绪，是如何把雅典拖入数十年的战争并最终走向失败的。傲慢与复仇。我的意思是，这往往是所有黄金时代的核心，不是吗？厄运和灾难即将降临的想法。你正身处派对之中，但宿醉已隐约逼近。
As for Augustine Rome, I mean, how much is that? are coming you're in the middle of the party but the hangover is looming um as for august and rome i mean how much is that so again uh there's a different way that lots of people ronald simon so on have described that period as the imposition of an autocracy um after the sort of slightly creative anarchy of the republic that um there's a dark side to Augustus as a dictator, that all this is pure propaganda to justify his regime. I mean, that would be the obvious counter-argument, wouldn't it? That this is a golden age of a Roman totalitarian. He's not totalitarian, but yes, I mean, undoubtedly,
至于奥古斯都时期的罗马，我的意思是，这有多大程度……正在逼近，你正身处派对之中，但宿醉已隐约逼近……至于奥古斯都时期的罗马，我的意思是，这有多大程度……同样，还有另一种观点，许多人（如罗纳德·西姆等人）将那个时期描述为在共和国略具创造性的无政府状态之后，对专制政权的强加，奥古斯都作为一个独裁者有其黑暗的一面，所有这些纯粹是为他的政权辩护的宣传。我的意思是，显而易见的反驳观点会是这样，不是吗？这是一个罗马极权主义者的黄金时代。他不是极权主义者，但是的，毫无疑问，
he's an autocratic figure. But against that, you know, where there had been war, he brings peace. And, you know, Virgil is just one of a number of poets who celebrate the achievements that, you know, the world of peace that Augustus has brought about. And I think that, that you know to this day it's looked back on as as an age of great cultural achievement um and of course it also has the overlay that comes from the fact that that jesus is born in augustus's life and so that virgilian prophecy has a kind of christian element as well but that doesn't matter for quite a while afterward. I mean- even once the kind of the hold of the literature of the period, which is massive on subsequent generations of Romans, once that starts to fade,
他是一个独裁人物。但与此相对的是，在曾经有战争的地方，他带来了和平。（你知道，维吉尔只是众多歌颂奥古斯都带来的成就和和平世界的诗人的其中之一。）我认为，直到今天，人们仍然将其视为一个具有巨大文化成就的时代，当然，它还叠加了另一个事实，即耶稣出生在奥古斯都的有生之年，因此维吉尔的预言也有了一种基督教的色彩，但这在相当长一段时间内并不重要。我的意思是——甚至一旦该时期文学的影响力（这对后来的罗马人产生了巨大影响）开始消退，
because Christians come to see it as having this cosmic significance. The age of Augustus is the time when Christ is born, when God enters earth. Therefore, it kind of massively dignifies it. But isn't that just one of three Roman golden ages, Tom? So first of all, just before Augustus comes onto the stage, there are people like Cato who have a sense that they're living in an age of luxury and dissolution. And before then, there was a purer, more decent Republican golden age that's now been lost well there's a there's a gold at the golden
因为基督徒开始认为它具有这种宇宙意义。奥古斯都时代是基督诞生、上帝降临地球的时代。因此，它在很大程度上赋予了这一时期尊严。但这难道不是三个罗马黄金时代中的一个吗，汤姆？所以首先，就在奥古斯都登台之前，像加图这样的人觉得他们生活在一个奢侈和解体的时代。在此之前，还有一个更纯洁、更正派的共和国黄金时代，而这个时代现在已经丢失了……好吧，还有一个黄金时代，
age where saturn had ruled as king of italy on the capital that really is kind of quite a lost golden age the the idea of of kind of early rome as uh as virtuous and a noble um an age before they got corrupted by greek sex manuals and celebrity chefs and the like um it's it's not exact it's not exactly golden age though is it because it's it's it's an age when there isn't any gold that's the whole point they're virtuous because they they don't have gold they have nothing yeah they have turnips and they have war and they have their devotion to duty. And what more does anyone need? Great dad's army. So what about the, what I would say is the third great Roman golden age.
当时萨图尔尼（Saturn）作为意大利国王在卡питол（Capitoll）统治，那确实是一个相当失落的黄金时代，早期罗马被视为道德高尚、崇高……在他们被希腊性爱手册、名厨之流腐蚀之前的那个时代……不过，这不完全是黄金时代，对吧？因为它是一个根本没有黄金的时代，这正是重点所在。他们道德高尚，因为他们没有黄金，他们一无所有，是的，他们只有芜菁，有战争，还有他们对职责的忠诚。任何人还需要什么？伟大的“爸爸的军队”（Dad's Army）。那么，第三个伟大的罗马黄金时代又是什么呢？
And this is the one that lots of listeners will be familiar with. Tom McTague sent in a question about it. The golden age of the Antonines. So this is the, Edward Gibbon talks about this in The Decline of Fall of the Roman Empire. And he says very famously, a quote you'll be familiar with, Tom, if a man were called upon to fix the period in the history of the world during which the condition of the human race was most happy and prosperous, he would without hesitation name that which elapsed from the death of Domitian to the accession of Commodus.
这就是许多听众都会熟悉的那个。汤姆·麦克泰格（Tom McTague）发来了一个关于它的问题。安东尼王朝的黄金时代。爱德华·吉本在《罗马帝国衰亡史》中谈到了这一点。他说了一句非常著名的名言，汤姆，你一定会熟悉：“如果有人被要求确定世界历史上人类状况最幸福和繁荣的时期，他会毫不犹豫地指出从图密善死后到康茂德即位这段时间。”
So it's the Age of the Antonines, Marcus Aurelius, Antoninus Pius, and so on. Was that a golden age? Well, there's another question from Will Rester, did the Romans believe at the peak of the empire that they were living in a golden age? And the answer is that one guy certainly did. And he was a man from what's now Turkey called Aelius Aristides, who in 154 came to Rome. He was a famous orator. And he basically, you know, he spoke to the imperial court and he said, Rome is brilliant. They must have been delighted by that.
所以这就是安东尼王朝时代，马可·奥勒留、安东尼·庇护等等。那是一个黄金时代吗？好吧，维尔·雷斯特（Will Rester）提出了另一个问题：罗马人在帝国鼎盛时期是否相信他们生活在黄金时代？答案是，有一个人绝对是这么认为的。他是一个来自现在土耳其的人，名叫埃利乌斯·阿里斯蒂德（Aelius Aristides），他在154年来到罗马。他是一位著名的演说家。他基本上……（他向帝国宫廷发表了演讲），他说罗马太棒了。他们一定对此感到高兴。
They were. They absolutely loved it. And he described Rome as a great garden, the empire as a garden, that always kind of order and beautiful orchards and things like that. And that, you know, the weeds had all been pulled up and everything was fabulous. And it's that that Gibbon is drawing on, basically, in his opening to the decline and fall of the Roman Empire. Yeah.
他们确实很高兴。他们绝对喜欢它。他把罗马描述为一个伟大的花园，将帝国描述为一个花园，那里总是井然有序，有着美丽的果园之类的东西。你知道，杂草都被拔掉了，一切都好极了。吉本在《罗马帝国衰亡史》的开篇中，基本上正是借鉴了这一点。是的。
And, of course, what gives it the edge is that is that we know what's coming and and actually i think i'm right that ilius aristides in due course dies of the plague that hits the roman empire in the in the reign of marcus aurelius and which is a kind of you know it it's the first of numerous pandemics that sweep over the empire in the late second and throughout the third century and kind of merges with the convulsions of civil war that basically means that people inevitably in the third century are looking back to this time.
当然，让它更具戏剧性的是，我们知道接下来会发生什么。实际上，如果我没记错的话，埃利乌斯·阿里斯蒂德最终死于马可·奥勒留统治时期袭击罗马帝国的瘟疫，这是一种……（它是席卷公元2世纪末和整个3世纪帝国的众多大流行病中的第一个），并与内战的动荡交织在一起，这意味着3世纪的人们不可避免地会回首那个时代。
Yeah, crisis of the third century and all that kind of debased coinage and inflation and stuff. So an age of gold is followed by an age of iron. So does that suggest, therefore, that the idea of a golden age is kind of, it's absolutely inherent in the classical world sense of time, that there's a kind of cyclical, you know, the pendulum swings, age of gold, age of lead or whatever. Well, I think that the enshrining of of fifth century athens and augustan
是的，三世纪危机以及所有那些贬值的币制、通货膨胀之类的事情。所以一个黄金时代之后是一个铁器时代。这是否暗示着，黄金时代的观念在某种程度上，是绝对内在于古典世界的时间观念中的，即存在一种循环的模式，（你知道，钟摆摇摆，黄金时代、铅器时代等等）。好吧，我认为将公元前5世纪的雅典和奥古斯都时期的罗马
rome as kind of twin pin twin peaks is a feature of how the roman world understands the past and indeed the hellenistic world because so one of the key things in enshrining athens as a golden age is the the sense that um say aeschylus uh sophocles euripides the great tragedians that these are the top three these are the top tragedians sense of a canon so it's so in alex yes exactly and so in alexandria when they build the library they ask the athenians could we have the copies of the plays and the athenians say yeah but you've got to pay a massive deposit because otherwise you'll never get it back to us. So they send the copies to Alexandria and the Alexandrians say, fine, but the tragedians of Athens of 5th century Athens are the classics, really beds down the idea that that was a golden age.
奉为双子峰，是罗马世界理解过去（乃至希腊化世界）的一个特征。因为将雅典奉为黄金时代的关键要素之一，是这样一种观念：比如埃斯库罗斯、索福克勒斯、欧里庇得斯等伟大的悲剧作家，他们是顶级的三位，他们是顶级悲剧作家，这种经典的概念。所以它在亚历山大……是的，完全正确。所以在亚历山大，当他们建造图书馆时，他们要求雅典人：我们能借到戏剧的抄本吗？雅典人说：行，但你们得付一大笔押金，否则你们永远不会把它还给我们。于是他们把抄本寄给亚历山大，亚历山大人说：没问题，但公元前5世纪雅典的悲剧作家才是真正的经典，这深深巩固了那是一个黄金时代的观念。
And the same happens for Roman education that Virgil and Horace and Ovid and so on get enshrined. And that, of course, then feeds through into the Middle Ages. And I do think that Athens and Augustine Rome kind of underpin the idea of golden ages for people in Europe. So you think of the Raphael painting, the School of Athens. Yeah. That is what a golden age is. And, of course, then it informs the Renaissance. Yeah.
罗马教育也是如此，维吉尔、贺拉斯和奥维德等人都被奉为经典。当然，这随后延续到了中世纪。我确实认为，雅典和奥古斯都时期的罗马是欧洲人黄金时代观念的基石。所以你会想到拉斐尔的画作《雅典学院》。是的。那就是黄金时代的模样。当然，它随后也启发了文艺复兴。是的。
But these golden ages, they're about power, aren't they? They're very powerful states that have exerted influence over their neighbours, that have won wars, that are now at peace. and that's the question that harry lime's piece focuses does a golden age is it okay for it just to be an age of great cultural achievement like renaissance italy or does it have to be an age of of military and economic power as well well i don't i don't think harry lime is right because i mean we've talked a little bit in this podcast before about how, for example, in the 17th century, people had an idea of the Norman yoke. And implicit in that is the idea that Anglo-Saxon England was a kind of golden age when people would meet and decide in assemblies the laws and the future of their society, when the heavy hand of the Normans with their castles and their knights and their feudalism had not yet crushed the spirits of the english working man so that's one golden age right i mean
但这些黄金时代，它们关乎权力，不是吗？它们是强大的国家，对邻国施加了影响，赢得了战争，如今迎来了和平。这就是哈里·莱姆的那段话所关注的问题：黄金时代是否可以仅仅是一个像文艺复兴时期的意大利那样拥有伟大文化成就的时代，还是说它也必须是一个军事和经济强权的时代？好吧，我不认为哈里·莱姆是对的，因为我们在这个播客中之前稍微探讨过，例如在17世纪，人们有一种诺曼枷锁的观念。其中隐含的观点是，盎格鲁-撒克逊时期的英格兰是一种黄金时代，当时人们会聚在一起，在集会上决定法律和社会的未来，而诺曼人带着他们的城堡、骑士和封建主义的沉重之手尚未粉碎英国劳动人民的精神，所以这是一个黄金时代，对吧？我的意思是
that's and that idea that's very that was very popular with the victorians and indeed it was popular with sort of it's actually there in kind of progressive thinking a little bit that there was a a kinder gentler more bucolic age, which has been lost with the kind of, you know, it's kind of Hobbiton, isn't it? It's the Shire. Yes. Tolkien's golden age is very much related to that. I mean, that's got nothing to do with imperialism and winning wars. And because Anglo-Saxon was not a country that went out and fought wars, by and large. Well, it was an age in which there was a lot of slavery and the normal conquest got rid of it so it's almost the opposite of the truth right well i mean you can say the same about pericle
这……这种观点在维多利亚时代非常流行，事实上它也很受欢迎……它其实在某种程度上存在于某种进步思想中，即存在一个更善良、更温和、更田园诗般的时代，随着……（你知道，这有点像霍比顿，不是吗？这就是夏尔。）是的托尔金的黄金时代与此息息相关。我的意思是，这与帝国主义和赢得战争毫无关系。因为盎格鲁-撒克逊不是一个走出去打仗的国家，大体上如此。好吧，那是一个奴役现象严重、诺曼征服消除了这种现象的时代，所以这几乎与事实相反，对吧？好吧，我的意思是，你对伯利克里
in athens though couldn't you and it goes of course there's a lot of slavery and there's a very big gap between rich and poor so it's not a golden age for everybody no absolutely not and and golden ages generally depend on it not being golden ages for other people right i mean almost by definition um um because because because uh you know what is it the the walter benjamin thing that there is no monument to civilization that is not also a monument to barbarism right exactly the parthenon was paid for out of the tax that you know the donations that the athenians extorted from the delian league and western rome was founded on obviously kind of you know, the donations that the Athenians extorted from the Delian League and Augustan Rome was founded on, obviously, kind of, you know, the mass exploitation of the provinces.
时期的雅典也可以这么说，不是吗？当然存在大量奴隶制，而且穷人和富人之间存在巨大的差距，所以对每个人来说，这都不是一个黄金时代。不，绝对不是。黄金时代通常取决于对其他人而言不是黄金时代，对吧？我的意思是，几乎按定义来说……因为……因为……（你知道，瓦尔特·本雅明的那句话是什么来着？）没有一道文明的丰碑，同时也是野蛮的丰碑，对吧？正是如此。帕台农神庙是用雅典人从提洛同盟勒索的税收（捐款）支付的，而奥古斯都时期的罗马显然建立在……（你知道的），对各行省的大规模剥削之上。
And I guess you'd say the same of kind of more recent gold. I mean, because you see, I do slightly wonder about golden ages, that I think that the closer we, I think Athens and Rome are kind of, they have a mythic quality because they're removed from us and they're distant from us. But in more recent times, I mean, can you seriously talk about a European state having a golden age? I would say maybe 16th century Spain, 17th century, the Netherlands, but I'm just going to say every week, Tom Holland brings me up and says, when are we going to do the golden age of the Dutch Republic?
我想你对更近一些的黄金时代也会这么说。因为你看，我确实对黄金时代有些疑惑，我认为雅典和罗马具有某种神话色彩，因为它们离我们很远，与我们有距离。但在更近的时期，我的意思是，你能严肃地谈论一个欧洲国家拥有黄金时代吗？我会说是16世纪的西班牙，17世纪的荷兰，但我正要说的是，汤姆·霍兰每周都会提起并对我说：我们什么时候要讲荷兰共和国的黄金时代？
I mean, you're famously obsessed with your namesake country and desperate to do that golden age. So you do think that, right? I mean, you mentioned the golden age of Spain. People do talk about it. I mean, clearly, Spain was a top nation in the 16th century. I mean, gold, literally gold flooding in from South America from its conquests.
我的意思是，你出了名地痴迷于以你的名字命名的国家，并且极度渴望做那一期的黄金时代。所以你确实是这么想的，对吧？我的意思是，你提到了西班牙的黄金时代。人们确实在谈论它。我的意思是，很显然，西班牙在16世纪是一个顶级国家。我的意思是，黄金，从南美洲的征服中如潮水般涌入的字面上的黄金。
Tremendous explosion of, you know, of artistic creativity and so on. I mean, Charles V is, you know, the most powerful man in the world by a billion miles. And it's again, it's that pattern, isn't it? Spain is not so powerful in the 17th century starts to become a bit of a basket case in the 18th century total basket case in the 19th and part of the 20th century civil war and then you know franco and so on so obviously the the 16th
艺术创造力等的巨大爆发。我的意思是，查理五世是……（以十亿英里计）世界上最强大的人。这又是那个模式，不是吗？西班牙在17世纪不再那么强大，在18世纪开始变得有点像个烂摊子，在19世纪和20世纪一部分彻底成了烂摊子——内战，然后是……（你知道）弗朗哥等等。所以很显然，16世纪
century looms large and it would seem to me i mean obviously if i was in a spanish history seminar i wouldn't say this out loud but i might i'd be thinking it just seemed to me, I mean, obviously, if I was in a Spanish history seminar, I wouldn't say this out loud, but I'd be thinking it. It just seemed to me bonkers to pretend that the 16th century wasn't the top century for Spain. Yes. But I think in the case of Spain, a lot of the cultural peaks kind of follow on from it. And they look forward. They kind of... So you've got Cervantes, Don Quixote.
意义重大，在我看来……当然，如果我身处西班牙历史研讨会上，我不会大声说出来，但我心里会这么想……在我看来，如果假装16世纪对西班牙来说不是最顶峰的世纪，那就是疯了。是的。但我认为，就西班牙而言，许多文化巅峰实际上是随之而来的。它们面向未来。它们有点……所以你有塞万提斯的《堂吉诃德》。
Yeah. Who mistakes windmills for giants. Well, he's kind of in that cusp, isn't he? So he's on the cusp. He's looking back to an age of chivalry. And then you've got Velazquez. Yeah. You know, these paintings of the court that is kind of, you know,
是的。他把风车误当作巨人。好吧，他有点处于那个交界处，不是吗？所以他处于转折点。他回首一个骑士精神的时代。然后你有委拉斯开兹。是的。你知道，这些宫廷画作……
there's a lot of vulnerability there in Velázquez's paintings. And I think that the effect of that is retrospectively to cast 16th century Spain as being slightly, its decline is hardwired into its period greatness. Well, that's definitely true, but that's true of all golden ages though, isn't it? You said it at Periclean Athens. You know the plague is coming. You know the Peloponnesian War is coming. I'm not sure.
委拉斯开兹的画作中有很多脆弱感。我认为其效果是，回顾性地将16世纪的西班牙塑造成……其衰落已经深深烙印在其时期的伟大之中。好吧，这绝对是真的，但这适用于所有的黄金时代，不是吗？你在伯利克里时期的雅典就说过这一点。你知道瘟疫要来了。你知道伯罗奔尼撒战争要来了。我不确定。
No, I'm not sure that's right. I think you think the Parthenon is amazing or Virgil is amazing. These are great achievements. I think with, with Spain, the greatness is actually in questioning the idea of greatness. Okay. Okay. Is that,
不，我不确定那是对的。你认为帕台农神庙令人惊叹，或者维吉尔令人惊叹。这些是伟大的成就。我认为对于西班牙来说，伟大实际上在于对伟大观念的质疑。好吧。好吧。是这样吗？
is that, I mean, I'm slightly thinking on the cuff. Let's hope there's Spanish specialists to listen to this. What about Elizabethan England? I mean, there was a film, the second Elizabeth film of the Cate Blanchett films,
我的意思是，我有点在即兴思考。希望听这个节目的听众中有西班牙专家。伊丽莎白时代的英格兰呢？我的意思是，有一部电影，凯特·布兰切特主演的第二部伊丽莎白电影，
is called Elizabeth, The Golden Age. And people always, I mean, my Ladybird books when I was a child, talked about the golden age of Elizabethan England, William Shakespeare, Sir Francis Drake. Defeating the Spanish Armada. I was just about to say, sending the Spanish Armada packing. We obviously don't mention all the naval battles we lost um and our own attempts uh they're strangely um not present in the histories but yeah i mean that sense of elizabethan england is a golden age is absolutely it has
叫做《伊丽莎白：黄金时代》。人们总是……我的意思是，我小时候读的瓢虫书（Ladybird books）谈到过伊丽莎白时代英格兰的黄金时代，威廉·莎士比亚，弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士。击败西班牙无敌舰队。我正要说呢，把西班牙无敌舰队打得落花流水。我们显然不会提及我们输掉的所有海战，以及我们自己的尝试……它们奇怪地……没有出现在历史中，但是的，我的意思是，伊丽莎白时代的英格兰作为一个黄金时代的这种感觉，绝对……世世代代以来，
for generations been hardwired into the british national consciousness hasn't it or these the english national consciousness yes it's an age of maypoles and Mary England. Right, exactly. And it's clearly not true. Yeah. But I mean, I think... That's the problem. I think it's an age of inflation and plague. Yes.
它已经深深烙印在英国国民意识中了，不是吗？或者说英格兰国民意识？是的，那是一个五朔节和欢乐英格兰（Merry England）的时代。对，没错。这显然不是真的。是的。但我的意思是，我认为……这就是问题所在。我认为那是一个充满通货膨胀和瘟疫的时代。是的。
Elizabeth having very bad teeth. Isolation. Paranoia about Catholic plots and all those kinds of things. Hostility with Europe. Yes. Plague. Yeah. Inflation.
伊丽莎白有一口非常糟糕的牙齿。孤立。对天主教阴谋的偏执以及诸如此类的事情。与欧洲的敌对。是的。瘟疫。是的。通货膨胀。
So you could say all those... Problems with supply lines. Right. you could say all those. Problems with supply lines. Right. You could say all those things about. People look back and say 2021, a golden year. But couldn't you say that about all these periods, that they're fictionalized, confected, kind of romanticized to some extent? But I mean, I reckon that the reason that people think of Tudor England,
所以你可以把所有这些……供应链问题。没错。你可以把所有这些……供应链问题。没错。你可以把所有这些关于……人们回首过去，说2021年是一个黄金年份。但难道你不能对所有这些时期都这么说吗？它们在某种程度上都被虚构了、捏造了、浪漫化了？但我的意思是，我估计人们之所以认为都铎英格兰、
Elizabethan England as a golden age is principally because of Shakespeare, because Shakespeare is seen as... Top writer. You know, our top writer. Yeah.
伊丽莎白时代的英格兰是一个黄金时代，主要是因为莎士比亚，因为莎士比亚被视为……顶级作家。你知道的，我们的顶级作家。是的。
Top global writer. Yeah. But of course, I mean, you know, Shakespeare, you know, a lot of his greatest plays were written under James and nobody can say that James is a you know Jacobean England is a golden age because
全球顶级作家。是的。但当然，我的意思是（你知道），莎士比亚（你知道），他的许多最伟大的戏剧都是在詹姆斯统治时期写的，没有人会说詹姆斯是一个……（你知道）詹姆斯一世时期的英格兰是一个黄金时代，因为
he's Stuart so the civil wars are coming yeah but I think it's entirely down to it's not just Shakespeare but it's also the contrast between Elizabeth I, Gloriana Virgin Queen all that kind of stuff with the Stuarts but I think it's also the contrast between Elizabeth I, Gloriana, Virgin Queen, all that kind of stuff, with the Stuarts.
他是斯图亚特王朝的人，所以内战即将来临。是的，但我认为这完全归结于……不仅是莎士比亚，还有伊丽莎白一世、荣耀安娜、童贞女王所有这些与斯图亚特王朝的对比。但我认为这也归结于伊丽莎白一世、荣耀安娜、童贞女王所有这些与斯图亚特王朝的对比。
But I don't think it's... But see, I think that's the key. I think the 1590s were a terrible time. See, I think that's the key to this whole issue, Gordon, is that contrast. It's not the age itself. It's the often politically drawn comparison with the period that follows it.
但我不认为……你看，我认为这才是关键。我认为1590年代是一个糟糕的时期。你看，我认为整个问题的关键，戈登，就在于这种对比。这并不是时代本身。这是与紧随其后的时期进行的、往往带有政治色彩的比较。
Maybe we should take a break, Tom, and then we should come back and talk about, see, I think there's a lot to be said about 20th century golden ages, the idea of falling away from a period of virtue and so on. And we should do some more questions. So we'll see you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
也许我们该休息一下，汤姆，然后回来谈谈……你看，我认为关于20世纪的黄金时代有很多值得说的，比如从美德时期堕落的观念等等。我们应该回答更多问题。所以我们休息后见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝娱乐圈八卦的固定去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com hello welcome back to the rest is history and dominic uh on the subject of golden ages yes of course one of the key aspects of golden ages was that um people with things to say had to be provided with platforms didn't they they did they did uh there were many platforms available but one in particular i think looms large in our minds tom doesn't it it does it does um it's uh it's an online magazine that very very kindly has uh sponsored us uh it's called unheard and i'm reading here their own self-description. It looks at today's events through a wider lens of history and philosophy and is full of independent thinking and writing. And it's full of really great writing. Is it?
那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》，多米尼克，关于黄金时代这个话题，是的，当然，黄金时代的关键方面之一是，有话要说的人必须获得平台，不是吗？他们确实有，他们确实有……有许多平台可供选择，但我认为其中有一个在我们的脑海中尤为突出，汤姆，不是吗？确实如此，确实如此……这是一个非常非常友好地赞助了我们的在线杂志……它叫 Unherd，我在这里读它自己的自我描述。它通过历史和哲学的更广阔镜头审视今天的事件，充满了独立的思考和写作。而且它充满了真正精彩的文章。是吗？
I think it is full of great writing. I think it's it's not fair to say that some of Britain's absolute top, top, top historians write for Unheard. Is that right? Top podcasting historians. Yes. Can you think of any in particular? Well, Dominic, right, for UnHerd? Is that right? Top podcasting historians. Yes. Can you think of any in particular? Well, Dominic, I can think of you. Because last week, did you not, you wrote a piece about how we might be returning to 1970s-style high inflation?
我认为它确实充满了精彩的文章。我认为说英国一些最顶尖、最顶尖、最顶尖的历史学家为 Unherd 撰稿，这并不过分，对吧？顶级播客历史学家。是的。你能想到任何具体的人吗？好吧，多米尼克，为 Unherd 撰稿？是这样吗？顶级播客历史学家。是的。你能想到任何具体的人吗？好吧，多米尼克，我能想到你。因为上周，你难道不是写了一篇文章，关于我们可能如何回到20世纪70年代风格的高通胀？
Chilling. A chilling piece, I think, is the technical term. Such was life in the summer of 1975, you wrote in UnHerd. The age of Shawoddy Woddy, 10cc in the Bay City Rollers. Harold Wilson was PM. Tom Baker was in his time-travelling pomp. Britain had just voted to remain in the common market. And the space hopper was the fashion accessory du jour.
令人不寒而栗。一篇令人不寒而栗的文章，我想这是专业术语。你在 Unherd 中写道，这就是1975年夏天的生活。那是 Showaddywaddy、10cc 和贝城溜冰者乐队（Bay City Rollers）的时代。哈罗德·威尔逊（Harold Wilson）是首相。汤姆·贝克（Tom Baker）正处于他穿越时空的全盛时期。英国刚刚投票决定留在共同市场。太空跳跳球（space hopper）是当季的时尚配饰。
You see, even as you're reading that, people are leaving this podcast and flocking. They're flooding. Actually, they're flooding onto Unheard's website to read this top punditry. But I'm not wrong, am I, to say that top historians of the ancient and medieval worlds also write for Unheard, don't they? That's right. Yes. I also have written for it. This is a great spontaneous chat, isn't it?
你看，甚至在你朗读的时候，人们都在离开这个播客并蜂拥而至。他们正蜂拥而至。事实上，他们正涌向 Unherd 的网站来阅读这些顶级的政治评论。但我并没有错，对吧？说古代和中世纪世界的顶级历史学家也为 Unherd 撰稿，不是吗？没错。是的。我也为它写过文章。这是一场很棒的即兴聊天，不是吗？
Right. So, yes, it is. It is. So, Dominic, both you and I write for UnHerd, which is an excellent reason, I think, for our listeners to rush off to unheard. So our listeners, we are absolutely spoiling people. We really are. Yes, we really are. Unheard.com slash rest. And if you don't enjoy it, you can just unsubscribe. So that is truly an offer worthy of a golden age, is it not? I mean, I'm talking of not enjoying it.
对，所以，是的，确实如此。确实如此。所以，多米尼克，你和我都在为 Unherd 撰稿，我认为这是一个绝佳的理由，敦促我们的听众赶快去访问 Unherd。所以我们的听众，我们绝对是在宠爱大家。我们真的是这样。是的，我们真的是这样。Unherd.com/rest。如果你不喜欢，你可以直接取消订阅。所以这绝对是一个配得上黄金时代的优惠，不是吗？我的意思是，说到不喜欢，
The script says you can read Tom Holland on how Hitler killed the devil or how Martin Luther would rule Twitter. Now, we've done a podcast on that. Did you write that before or after the podcast? I wrote after so he just ripped off the podcast no no the podcast informed my views i refined them yeah i cut out the bits that you contributed and then exactly there you go yeah an offering worthy of a golden age so i think that's enough that's enough advertising let Let's get back to Golden Ages. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History. We are talking Golden Ages. And in the first half,
脚本上说你可以阅读汤姆·霍兰关于希特勒如何杀死魔鬼或马丁·路德将如何统治推特的文章。现在，我们已经就此做过一期播客了。你是在这期播客之前还是之后写的？我是之后写的，所以他只是抄袭了播客……不，不，这期播客启发了我的观点，我提炼了它们，是的，我删去了你贡献的那部分，然后……完全正确，就是这样，一个配得上黄金时代的奉献。所以我想这足够了，广告已经够了，让我们回到黄金时代。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们正在探讨黄金时代。在上半场，
we were kind of focusing very much on ancient Golden Ages, early modern Golden Ages. But Dominic, if we look at more contemporary history, would you say that, say, if we look back to the 50s, there's a kind of conservative take that that was a golden age. Absolutely. When you look to the 60s, there's a kind of progressive take that that was a golden age. Is it possible for one's sense of what a golden age is to be determined by one's politics? is it possible for one's sense of what a golden age is to be determined
我们非常专注于古代黄金时代、早期现代黄金时代。但多米尼克，如果我们看看更当代的历史，你会说，比如说，如果我们回看50年代，有一种保守派的看法认为那是一个黄金时代。绝对是的。当你看到60年代时，有一种进步派的看法认为那是一个黄金时代。一个人对黄金时代的理解，有可能由其政治立场决定吗？一个人对黄金时代的理解，有可能由其政治立场决定
by one's politics? It is determined by one's politics, I think, when you're thinking about post-war history. And actually, I wouldn't even start in the 50s. Ken Loach recently did a film, Spirit of 45. Yes, of course. And there are people at Labour Party conferences who wear T-shirts that say,
由其政治立场决定吗？我认为，当你在思考战后历史时，它是由一个人的政治立场决定的。事实上，我甚至不会从50年代开始。肯·洛奇（Ken Loach）最近拍了一部电影《45年的精神》。是的，当然。工党会议上有穿着T恤的人，上面写着：
what would Clem do? In reference to the Attlee government post-war so but do they but no one no one thinks that you know austerity britain was a golden age you clearly don't read the comments under the articles in the guardian website tom i mean you you'll happily promote their saturday newspaper but you're clearly not digging deep enough into the um into the website because if you read the comments, lots of people say, oh, that was a time when people looked out for each other, when we had a government that was pure, when there was a real, it was tough times,
克莱姆会怎么做？（Clem指战后艾德礼政府）所以……但他们……没有人认为（你知道）紧缩政策下的英国是一个黄金时代……你显然没有读《卫报》网站文章底下的评论，汤姆，我的意思是，你会高兴地推广他们的周六报纸，但你显然没有深入挖掘……网站的评论区，因为如果你看评论，很多人说，哦，那是一个人们守望相助的时代，我们有一个清廉的政府，有一种真实的……虽然那是艰难时期，
but a real collective spirit and people pulled together. Tough times. They showed compassion. But you can't have a golden age if the times are tough. But this is, well, that's a different, that's your kind of golden age that is like early Rome. You know, you said turnips and war. Yes, absolutely.
但有着真正的集体精神，人们齐心协力。艰难时期。他们表现出同情心。但如果时期艰难，你就不能拥有黄金时代。但这……好吧，那是另一回事，那是你那种类似于早期罗马的黄金时代。你知道的，你说过芜菁和战争。是的，绝对的。
There's a kind of austere golden age, which is we had nothing but people. Civic virtue. Civic virtue. It's so funny. So there's a question on that. Where is it? Yes, Steve from Portslade. To what extent is the judgment of a golden age a moral one?
有一种简朴的黄金时代，意思是除了人，我们一无所有。公民美德。公民美德。太有趣了。所以有一个关于这个的问题。在哪里？是的，来自波茨拉德（Portslade）的史蒂夫（Steve）。对黄金时代的判断在多大程度上是一种道德判断？
Yeah. I.e. golden age as we look at as examples of virtue and lost values. See, I don't think that is necessarily a golden age. So I don't think that the Attlee government is seen as a golden age any more than the Romans saw, you know, the kind of early years of the Republic as a golden age. They saw them as virtuous ages. Right. But I don't think that's quite the same. Well, it's maybe slightly different.
对。也就是说，当我们把黄金时代当作美德和失落价值观的例子来看待时。你看，我不认为那必然是一个黄金时代。所以，我不认为艾德礼政府被视为黄金时代，就像罗马人没有把共和国的早期看作黄金时代一样。他们把它们视为有美德的时代。对。但我觉得这不太一样。嗯，可能有点不同。
Maybe slightly different. I agree with you. Or maybe you could say 60s is because the 60s is a great explosion not just of kind of cultural achievement but it's it's prosperity it's well i think people some people would say the 50s were a golden age so they would say you're right there's a slightly sort of um uh a sort of i was about to say peteritchens, but actually he always says he doesn't think the 50s were a golden age. But there's a definite conservative argument, you know, 50s, oh, you could leave your door unlocked, full employment, you know,
也许有点不同。我同意你的看法。或者你也可以说60年代是，因为60年代不仅是文化成就的大爆发，而且是繁荣，嗯，我想有些人会说50年代是黄金时代，所以他们会说你是对的，有点像嗯，一种，我正想说彼得·希特斯（Peter Hitchens），但实际上他总是说他不认为50年代是黄金时代。但确实存在一种保守派的论点，你知道，50年代，哦，你可以不锁大门，充分就业，你知道，
crime was allowed. No immigration. I mean, well, of course the 50s was the heyday of immigration. So, so much of this is based on complete mythology. By the way, as is the countervailing mythology of the 1960s. And those two things operate, obviously, in conflict with one another. You know, it's a sort of Beatles versus Stones, 50s versus 60s. You choose your fighter kind of thing.
犯罪率很低。没有移民。我的意思是，当然50年代是移民的全盛时期。所以，这里的很多说法都建立在彻头彻尾的神话之上。顺便说一句，1960年代针锋相对的神话也是如此。这两者显然在相互冲突中发挥作用。你知道，这有点像披头士对阵滚石乐队，50年代对阵60年代。有点像由你选择支持哪一方。
And absolutely true of America as well. Absolutely true of America. So, I mean, I think probably even more so, actually, that the 1950s and 1960s become kind of political tools in the 1980s and 1990s. Yeah. The two, you know, Clinton absolutely stands in the 1990s as the incarnation of 60s values and his enemies see him as such because they think the 60s were terrible. Now, the 70s, I mean, you can actually go through each of these sort of little slightly artificial chunks of post-war history i mean the 70s to some people when i often obviously write articles about the 70s and whenever i do there's the comments underneath are fascinating because some people will say the 70s were all inflation strikes terrorism is
对美国也完全适用。对美国也完全适用。所以，我的意思是，我认为可能更是如此，实际上，1950年代和1960年代在1980年代和1990年代变成了某种政治工具。对。这两者，你知道，克林顿在1990年代绝对代表了60年代价值观的化身，他的政敌也这样看待他，因为他们认为60年代糟透了。现在，70年代，我的意思是，你实际上可以回顾战后历史中这些稍微有点人工雕琢的片段，我的意思是，对某些人来说70年代，当我经常写关于70年代的文章时，每当我这么做，底下的评论都非常引人入胜，因为有些人会说70年代全都是通货膨胀、罢工、恐怖主义，
absolute misery anyone who claims it was great couldn't have been there and then the next comment will say what are you talking about you muppets the 70s were an absolute golden age we went to university we had grants we had unemployment wasn't as high that awful witch hadn't come in and destroyed all our industries blah blah blah so those things are very very politicized yeah so there's quite i mean on theme, there's a question from Rory Martin. Nostalgia plays a big part of national myths and identities. Given recent slogans like take back control and the MAGA, make America great again. Does that mean most politics has to be about a return to an Edenic past?
绝对的水深火热，任何宣称那个时期很棒的人当时一定不在现场；然后下一条评论就会说，你们这群笨蛋在胡说八道什么，70年代绝对是个黄金时代，我们上了大学，有助学金，失业率也没那么高，那个可怕的女巫还没上台摧毁我们所有的产业，等等等等。所以这些事情被高度政治化了。对。所以，挺契合主题的，罗里·马丁（Rory Martin）有一个问题。乡愁在国家神话和认同中扮演了重要角色。鉴于最近诸如“夺回控制权”和“MAGA”（让美国再次伟大）这样的口号，这是否意味着大多数政治都必须回归到一个伊甸园般的过去？
Well, I think it is, isn't it? I mean, there's always a sense. The nature of being a political opposition means that you are almost always saying there was a better age before the current government were in power and we've lost sight of what makes us great. Well, is that not true? It tends to be true of parties on the right than the left. I mean, I know that the left have nostalgia for Attlee or whatever or Roosevelt in America't know, Roosevelt in America or whatever. Yeah, the New Deal, great society. But, I mean, it's kind of important on the left
嗯，我想确实如此，不是吗？我的意思是，总有一种感觉。作为政治反对派的本质意味着，你几乎总是在说，在现任政府当权之前有一个更好的时代，而我们已经忘记了是什么让我们变得伟大。嗯，难道不是这样吗？右翼政党往往比左翼政党更倾向于这一点。我的意思是，我知道左翼对艾德礼或者美国的罗斯福或什么的怀有乡愁。不知道，美国的罗斯福什么的。对，新政，伟大社会。但是，我的意思是，对左翼来说这相当重要
to say that the best days are ahead of us, that we introduce better laws, we introduce better employment rights, and things will get better. Things can only get better. I mean, that's the... Well, that's your mate Tony's... So the golden age is projected into the future
那就是要说好日子还在后头，我们会引入更好的法律，更好的就业权，事情会变得更好。情况只会越来越好。我的意思是，那是……嗯，那是你的好朋友托尼的……所以黄金时代被投射到了未来。
i think there's a bit of both actually i think there was always a sense of a golden age in the past and particularly on the left in britain right now there's been a kind of sacralization of the atlee government of the 1940s and a sense that that was the only true labor government maybe less so the wilson government of the 60s you know because obviously they don't want to talk about blair because they people often regard blair as a sort of traitor and so on. But there is always a huge amount of nostalgia in left-wing thinking, I think. I mean, that stuff that we were talking about in the first half
我觉得实际上两者兼有，我觉得过去总有一种黄金时代的宿命感，特别是现在英国的左翼，对20世纪40年代的艾德礼政府有一种顶礼膜拜的感觉，认为那是唯一真正的工党政府，可能对60年代的威尔逊政府没那么大感觉，你知道，因为他们显然不想谈论布莱尔，因为人们通常认为布莱尔是个叛徒等等。但左翼思想中总是包含大量的怀旧情绪，我认为。我的意思是，我们在前半部分讨论过的那些
about the Anglo-Saxons and the Norman yoke, I mean, that's been there in British socialist thought since it was there in the late 19th century, early 20th century when the Labour Party was founded. No one invokes that now. I mean, I think this is kind of real different. Maybe they don't. I mean, it mattered to Michael
关于盎格鲁-撒克逊人和诺曼桎梏的事情，我的意思是，自19世纪末、20世纪初工党成立以来，这种情绪就一直存在于英国社会主义思想中。现在没有人提及这个了。我的意思是，我认为这有点完全不同。也许他们没有。我的意思是，这对迈克尔·
Foote. It mattered to Tony Bennet. It mattered to that generation. Does it matter to Corbyn fans? Does Keir Starmer talk about the Norman Yoke? Well, Keir Starmer wouldn't, but Corbyn hasn't, as far as I know. I'm not totally convinced about Jeremy Corbyn's close knowledge
富特（Michael Foot）很重要。这对托尼·本恩（Tony Benn）很重要。这对那一代人很重要。这对科尔宾的粉丝重要吗？基尔·斯塔默（Keir Starmer）会谈论诺曼桎梏吗？嗯，基尔·斯塔默不会，但据我所知，科尔宾也没有。我不太确信杰里米·科尔宾对
of British history, to be fair. You studied it at his public school. No, yes. Well, he's got an unfinished degree in trade union studies, hasn't he, from Polytechnic in North London? In that case, he must have it. No, I think politics is always an argument about the past as much as it is the present and the future.
英国历史有深入的了解，说实话。你在他的公立学校里学过这个。不，是的。嗯，他在北伦敦理工学院拿了个未完成的工会研究学位，不是吗？那样的话，他肯定学过。不，我认为政治始终是一场关于过去的争论，其激烈程度不亚于对现在和未来的争论。
And I think embedded in that is a sense of a falling away from an age of virtue. I absolutely think it's there, long tradition of political division. Yeah. That actually it's very difficult to agree on a kind of mutually accepted definition of a golden age. Yes, I do. And that's why I think the World War II in Britain is an exception to that because it's the one period where you have a national government that's put
我认为其中蕴含着一种对美德时代的偏离感。我绝对认为它是存在的，这是政治分歧的悠久传统。是的。实际上，很难就黄金时代的互惠共识定义达成一致。是的，我确实这么认为。这就是为什么我认为英国的二战是个例外，因为它是唯一一个各政党
aside party differences and their national interest. It's obviously a war we win. There's a sense of collective... It's a collective, but it's not a golden age because bombs are falling and there's... No, but you know what? So I mentioned Dad's Army. So in Dad's Army, which began in, I think, 1968,
放下党派分歧、将国家利益放在首位的时期。这显然是一场我们打赢了的战争。有一种集体感……这是一种集体，但它不是黄金时代，因为炸弹在落下，还有……不，但你知道吗？所以我提到了《老爸的军队》（Dad's Army）。所以在《老爸的军队》中，它始于，我想是1968年，
for those people who are not British, so this is an enormously, ridiculously popular sitcom about the Home Guard, the group of kind of largely elderly men, too old to fight, who were formed in the beginning of the Second World War to defend the country in case of a German invasion. So this is a sitcom about them but the framing device they use is a reunion dinner i mean people have forgotten this the whole thing is meant to be a flashback inside a framing device of a reunion dinner when captain mannering and the other characters are talking about
对于那些不是英国人的听众来说，这是一部非常、极其受欢迎的情景喜剧，讲的是“国民警卫队”，也就是一群年纪太大而不能参战的老年人，他们在二战初期组建起来，以防德国入侵时保卫国家。所以这是一部关于他们的情景喜剧，但他们使用的框架设定是一次重聚晚宴，我的意思是人们都忘了这一点，整部剧其实是曼宁（Mainering）队长和其他角色在谈论
um what has gone wrong with britain and they say you you know, we've lost sight of what drove us in World War II. And they're kind of looking back to a time when everybody pulled together. And there's an absolute sense that the World War was a golden age when people worked together. And that's been lost in the 1960s. Yeah, but it's not a golden age per se, I don't think. Well, you have a very specific description of golden age that involves a lot of poetry, I think.
嗯，英国出了什么问题时的一段倒叙，他们说，你知道的，我们忘记了在二战中驱动我们前进的力量。他们有点在回想那个每个人都齐心协力的时代。人们绝对认为二战是一个人们团结合作的黄金时代。而这种精神在1960年代丢失了。是的，但它本身并不是一个黄金时代，我不这么认为。嗯，你对黄金时代的定义非常具体，我想其中包含很多诗意。
I do. But also kind of success and prosperity. Yeah. So I think it's interesting, for instance, that we tend not to think of the Victorian period as a golden age. But I think people do think of the Victorian period as a golden age. No, because I think there's always been this kind of Dickensian shadow hanging over it. There's always been a sense of the workhouses and slums and industrial degradation and all that kind of stuff. And I think that's further complicated, obviously, by disagreements over the British Empire and so on. Like Britain, it's politically impossible to settle on any one period as being the golden age. And I think the same is true, say, of France, where there are lots of people who would say that the French Revolution was a golden age of egalitarian, fraternity, libertarian, that kind of stuff. But obviously, there are lots of French people who wouldn't.
确实如此。但同时也包含某种成功和繁荣。是的。所以我觉得很有趣的是，例如，我们往往不认为维多利亚时期是黄金时代。但我认为人们确实把维多利亚时期视为黄金时代。不，因为我认为狄更斯式的阴影一直笼罩着它。那种对济贫院、贫民窟、工业退化以及诸如此类事情的感觉一直存在。我认为，由于对大英帝国等问题存在分歧，情况显然变得更加复杂。就像英国一样，在政治上不可能确定任何一个单一时期就是黄金时代。我认为法国也是如此，有很多人会说法国大革命是平等、博爱、自由等价值观的黄金时代。但显然，许多法国人并不同意。
But don't they all look back to the reign of Louis XIV and think that was a golden age? No, I don't think Republicans would. No, maybe not, I suppose. So you don't think there can be a modern golden age? I mean, do you not think that... I think in modern European nations where
但他们难道不都回溯到路易十四的统治时期并认为那是黄金时代吗？不，我认为共和党人不会这么看。不，也许不会吧，我想。所以你不认为存在现代的黄金时代吗？我的意思是，你不认为……我认为在现代欧洲国家里，
there's an embedded history of left and right, of a profoundly different attitude, say, to the past, I think it's difficult to settle on a consensus, which is why I think that the last period that you can legitimately say, as a golden age, is kind of the 17th century in the Netherlands. Because it's not really political. It's not really, it's ceased to be political. It's about the kind of you know vermeer and and canals and uh tolerance and liberation and all this kind of stuff and who could object to that i mean
内在地存在着左右翼的历史，对过去有着截然不同的态度，比方说，很难达成一个共识，这就是为什么我认为你可以合情合理地称之为黄金时代的最后一个时期，大概是17世纪的荷兰。因为它不是真正的政治化。它真的不是，它已经不再是政治性的了。它是关于那种，你知道的，维米尔、运河、宽容、自由等等诸如此类的事情，谁会反对这个呢？我的意思是，
everyone loves all that everyone loves a canal and tolerance well the counter argument to that is that we had a ton of questions about the 1990s as a golden age and clearly a lot of people come to that do think of that so tom mctague who's of the atlantic monthly who's already asked we've allowed him to ask one question about edward gibbon he says when did our golden age end did it end in 1999 with the arrival of putin in september 2001 with iraq the invasion of iraq in 2003 with the crash of 2007 to 8 now implicit in that is the idea that up till then it was a golden age which we had only began in 1989 yeah and we had i i i don't have it here but i saw on twitter somebody asked a question saying the goal they felt the golden age was 1989 1990, when the world seemed to be getting inestimably better.
每个人都喜欢这些，每个人都喜欢运河和宽容。嗯，对此的反对意见是，我们收到了大量关于将1990年代视为黄金的问题，显然很多人来到这里确实是这么想的。所以《大西洋月刊》（The Atlantic Monthly）的汤姆·麦克塔格（Tom McTague）——他之前已经提过问了，我们允许他问一个关于爱德华·吉本（Edward Gibbon）的问题——他说，我们的黄金时代是什么时候结束的？它是在1999年普京登场时结束的？还是在2001年9月、2003年伊拉克战争爆发时？还是在2007至2008年的金融危机时结束的？这其中隐含的意思是，在那之前是一个黄金时代，而这个时代仅仅始于1989年。是的，我们曾有——我这里没有数据，但我看到推特上有人问了一个问题，说他们觉得黄金时代是1989到1990年，当时世界似乎在不可估量地变好。
I think now maybe this is a generational thing. And of course, golden ages can be quite generational things. But don't you think that for our generation, the 1990s feel like a golden age of creativity, economic affluence, optimism, all those kinds of things? And drugs. Not in Chipping norton um of course not um well yes although on top of that i mean it's something that you said earlier about about people saying the 70s were great yeah was that often people identify golden ages with their childhood i mean we did a whole episode on the 90s yeah we've already done this but uh yeah i mean i i think that uh the sense that uh the west had
我想现在这可能是一个代际问题。当然，黄金时代在很大程度上可能是一个代际问题。但你不认为对我们这一代人来说，1990年代感觉就像是一个充满创造力、经济富足、乐观主义等各种特质的黄金时代吗？还有毒品。在奇平诺顿（Chipping Norton）可没有，嗯，当然没有。嗯，是的，虽然除此之外，我的意思是，你之前说过关于有人说70年代很棒的话，嗯，那就是人们经常把黄金时代与他们的童年联系在一起，我的意思是，我们做了一整集关于90年代的节目，嗯，我们已经做过了，但是，是的，我的意思是，我认为，那种西方已经
won that the end of history was being reached that uh russia was not going to be a problem so i think tom tague is right to identify identify Putin as a kind of shadow over that. That everything was going to be kind of multiculturally harmonious. So again, 9-11 was a problem with that. That everyone would want to become a democracy. So yes, Iraq was a problem with that. And that we would just keep on getting richer and richer and everything was going to be fine. So yes, the crash was a problem with that and that we would just keep on getting richer and richer and everything was going to be fine so yes the crash was a problem with that so you've done a very good job of not not choosing
获胜、历史的终结已经到来、俄罗斯不再是一个问题的感觉……所以我认为汤姆·麦克塔格指出普京是笼罩在那之上的阴影是正确的。一切都将呈现多元文化上的和谐。所以同样地，9·11事件打破了这种想象。每个人都想成为民主国家。所以，是的，伊拉克战争打破了这种想象。我们将继续变得越来越富裕，一切都会好起来的。所以，是的，金融危机打破了这种想象，我们将继续变得越来越富裕，一切都会好起来的，所以，是的，金融危机打破了这种想象。所以你做得很好，没有选择
one of tom o'take's options i'd say the crash would you i'd have said september 11th actually i think september there was there was a definite sense of anxiety after september 11th i think um and a change in tone with the war on terror from what had just kind of changed in cultural tone. I do think you need money to have a golden age. Yeah, I think money is a huge part of it. And it's perfectly possible. Now, I suppose that the shadow that hangs over this podcast is, is the sense of a golden age gone for good because the future will be worse
汤姆·麦克塔格的选项之一。我会说金融危机，你会吗？我其实会说9·11事件，我认为9·11事件之后确实有一种焦虑感，嗯，随着反恐战争的爆发，文化基调发生了变化。我确实认为你需要金钱来创造一个黄金时代。是的，我认为金钱是其中很大一部分。这是完全可能的。现在，我想笼罩在这个播客之上的阴影是，黄金时代的感觉是否一去不复返了，因为未来会变得更糟糕，
than, you know, tomorrow will be worse than today because of climate change, because of there are so many people chasing fewer and fewer and fewer resources, all those kinds of things. What do you think about that? Yeah, I think there's a kind of dystopian shadow hanging over, well, everybody, obviously, on the planet. Maybe particularly for people in the West, because there's another, Luke Brennan asks, has the West as a whole had a golden age, or even is it still in one now? Is it arguable that since the Renaissance,
比起，你知道的，明天会比今天更糟，因为气候变化，因为有那么多人在争夺越来越少、越来越少、越来越少的资源，诸如此类的事情。你对此怎么看？是的，我认为有一种反乌托邦的阴影笼罩着，嗯，地球上的所有人，显然如此。可能对西方人来说尤其如此，因为另一个人，卢克·布伦南（Luke Brennan）问，整个西方是否经历过黄金时代，或者它现在是否仍然身处其中？有没有可能自从文艺复兴以来，
the whole world has had Western primacy for good and ill, and this still remains even with China's rise? If so, will the West's long golden age end soon? So I think that is a really good point, that in a sense, the West, if you're measuring it by economic and military primacy, the West collectively has enjoyed a golden age
整个世界都处于西方至上主义之下，无论好坏，而即使在中国崛起的情况下，这种局面依然存在？如果是这样，西方的漫长黄金时代会很快结束吗？所以我觉得这是一个非常好的观点，从某种意义上说，如果你用经济和军事首要地位来衡量，西方集体确实曾享有过一个黄金时代，
because it has had a kind of primacy which is definitely fading. And so the perspective, say, in India or China may be different. Yeah, I definitely think that's right. I think it's been an anomalous period of Western domination, hasn't it? I mean, China's an interesting one because there the idea of golden ages is kind of fundamental to the whole way that people throughout Chinese history
因为它曾拥有某种首要地位，而这种地位现在无疑正在消退。因此，比方说在印度或中国的视角可能会有所不同。是的，我绝对认为这是对的。我认为这是一个异常的西方统治时期，不是吗？我的意思是，中国是一个有趣的例子，因为在那里，黄金时代的理念从根本上贯穿于整个中国历史中，
understand the kind of the rhythms of the cosmos, really, that things kind of come into the correct balance. And then you have a golden age, and then things kind of slip out of balance again. Emperors lose the mandate of heaven and so on, and everything gets upended. Yes, surely that's right. I mean, obviously that's, you know, in a communist state like China is now, that's no longer kind of overtly felt or believed, but it must still be, I don't know enough about China to know,
人们借此理解宇宙的规律，真的，事物会恢复正确的平衡。然后你经历一个黄金时代，接着事物又会失衡。皇帝失去了天命等等，一切都被颠覆了。是的，当然是这样。我的意思是，很显然，你知道的，在一个像中国现在这样的共产主义国家里，这不再是一种公开的情感或信仰，但它一定仍然，我对中国了解不够，无法确知，
but I guess it must kind of be in the intellectual marrow. But surely, also, if you're one of the winners of today's China, you must have a very potent sense of living through a golden age of growth, of optimism, of cities will look back on now and say that was the moment when we were culturally, politically, economically more powerful than we had been for centuries. Do you not think? Yeah, I mean, I suppose that for the whole of Chinese history,
但我猜它一定某种程度上存在于知识分子的骨髓里。但当然，如果你是当今中国的赢家之一，你一定对经历这样一个增长、乐观、城市的黄金时代有着非常强烈的感受，人们在回顾现在时会说，那是我们在文化上、政治上、经济上比几个世纪以来都要强大的时刻。你不这么觉得吗？是的，我的意思是，我想在中国整个历史中，
people in China have, rather like the West has done, have been able to take for granted China's primacy, that it's central, that what's good for China is good for the world. And that the measure of whether there's a golden age or not is how well China is doing. And obviously, the 18th into the 19th century, the discovery that China wasn't the Middle Kingdom anymore, that it wasn't the center of world affairs it wasn't the fulcrum of world affairs okay you know i mean no one could believe that they were living in a golden age with that and now that now that china is kind of returning to its traditional position as the the pivotal nation on the face of the planet i don't know maybe maybe maybe the
中国的人们，很像西方曾经做过的那样，一直把中国的首要地位视为理所当然，认为它是核心，对中国好的事情对世界就是好的。衡量是否存在黄金时代的标准就是中国的发展状况。显然，从18世纪到19世纪，人们发现中国不再是“中央帝国”，不再是世界事务的中心，不再是世界事务的支点。好吧，你知道的，我的意思是，没有人能在那种情况下相信自己生活在黄金时代。而现在，既然中国正在回归其作为地球上关键国家的传统地位，我不知道，也许，也许历史作为一种由黄金时代被铁器时代取代的循环的感觉会再次抬头，我不知道，但我对中国了解不够，无法评说。一个我们可能应该谈论的国家，一个历史上从未真正有过黄金时代感觉的国家是美国，直到现在，我会这么说。所以，我的意思是，亨利·卢斯（Henry Luce）曾谈到20世纪将是美国世纪，并且一直有这样一种感觉，绝对承接了你刚才所说的话，关于政治，未来将总是更加光明，美国梦就是关于成功和最初不断扩大的前沿，然后基本上是
sense of history as a kind of cycle of golden ages replaced by ages of iron will will will kick back in i don't but i don't know enough about china to say i mean a country that we probably should be talking about it a country that's really never had a sense of a of a golden age in the past is the united states until now i would say so i mean henry lewis and that talked about the 20th century going to be the american century and there was always this sense that you know absolutely picking up something you were saying earlier that the the about politics that the future would always be brighter that the american dream was of success and of and initially an ever-expanding frontier and then basically
不断扩大的知识、文化、经济前沿。但大概自从——你可以在约翰·厄普代克（John Updike）的“兔子”系列小说中看到这种苗头，它们谈到伟大的美国旅程正在结束，现在在过去大约10年里，人们越来越强烈地感觉到——你几乎可以在所有美国公众的讨论中看到这一点——人们有一种感觉，美国最好的日子可能会……这种担忧认为美国最好的日子可能已经成为过去。我认为这是一个巨大的变化。如果相信这一点，那么大概存在一个黄金时代，
ever-expanding intellectual cultural economic frontiers but since probably i mean you can see the seeds of that in the 70s in john updyke's rabbit books they talk about the great american ride is ending and now very much in the last 10 years or so there's been a sense that you see it in almost all american public discourse a sense that america's best days may the fear that america's best days may lie in the past. And that's a big change, I think. Which would presumably, if you believe that, then presumably there's a golden age
你可以用来与当下进行衡量。嗯，黄金时代，我想，你在许多关于美国政治的评论中都能隐式地看到它。人们有一种感觉，黄金时代大约介于，比方说，珍珠港事件和越南战争之间。你不这么认为吗？罗斯福、杜鲁门和艾森豪威尔的总统任期，
by which you're measuring it against. Well, the golden age, I think, you see it absolutely implicitly in so much commentary about American politics. There's a sense that the golden age was between, let us say, Pearl Harbor and Vietnam. Do you not think? The presidencies of Roosevelt, Truman, and Eisenhower,
特别是肯尼迪的任期。不同之处在于，取决于你的政治倾向，你会更强调50年代还是60年代。对，完全如此。但你不认为有一种观点认为冷战赋予了道德确定性，美国肩负着使命，它在国内取得了进步，消除了偏见等等。我的意思是，再次回到那个话题，45年的新耶路撒冷或早期罗马共和国，一个充满美德的时期。我的意思是，美国人确实经历过那个。
and Kennedy maybe in particular. And with the difference, depending on what your politics is, whether you'd emphasize the 50s or the 60s. Yeah, exactly. But do you not think there's an idea that the Cold War gave moral certainty, that America had a mission, that it was making progress domestically and eradicating prejudice and so on. I mean, again, going back to that, the New Jerusalem of 45 or the early Roman Republic, a period of virtue. I mean, Americans did have that.
美德的时期是与国父们同在的。是的。对。美德，我的意思是美国人确实经历过那个。美德的时期与国父们同在。是的，我的意思是，那不是一个黄金时代，但那是一个取得了伟大成就的时代，我认为这略有不同。是的，但我想现在这正在经历，你知道的，现在这正在被重新审视，这些都是拥有奴隶的白人男性，所以，是的。所以这就是你的迭戈·莫尔加多（Diego Morgado）的观点，对，这就是黄金时代的论点。当然，正如我们所说，人们对伯利克里、雅典、奥古斯都时期的罗马也持有完全相同的看法。这些社会都是基于奴隶制和剥削的。所以我们是否在争论中得出了其实并不存在黄金时代的结论？
The period of virtue was with the founding fathers. Yes. Yeah. virtue i mean americans did have that the period of virtue was with the founding fathers yes yeah i mean it's not a golden age but it's an age that achieved great things which i think is slightly different yeah but i suppose that that is now coming you know that's now being refined these are all white men who own slaves so yeah that's so this is your diego diego morgado um yeah argument that's uh golden ages. And of course, people say exactly that, as we've said, about Pericles, about Athens, about Augustan Rome. These are societies about Ptolemaic Egypt or something.
我想我们可能正是如此，这非常、非常令人沮丧。嗯，我想我们应该以几个略显另类的问题来结束。所以戴夫·沃尔特斯（Dave Walters）问，现在是历史学家的黄金时代吗？如果不是，什么时候才是？你怎么看？嗯，很显然，我的意思是。
These are societies based on slavery and exploitation. So have we argued ourselves into thinking actually there aren't golden ages? I think we may be, which is very, very depressing. Well, I think we should end with a couple of slightly offbeat questions, though. So Dave Walters says, is now the golden age of historians? And if not, when? What do you think? Well, obviously, I mean.
我认为现在确实是历史学家的黄金时代，不是吗？我的意思是，现在写出来的历史书更多了，关于……我们对历史的了解比以往任何时候都要多，或者说也许……好吧，也许历史学家的黄金时代显然是公元前5世纪，正如我所知，那是修昔底德的时代。嗯，不过那只有两个人，不是吗？我的意思是，是的，但那只有两个人。是的，再举两个更具标志性的历史学家。
I think it is the golden age of historians, though, isn't it? I mean, there are more history books being written now, about more we know more about history than any body before or is less well maybe i mean maybe the golden age of historians was obviously uh fifth century bc as i know that's some thucydides well that's only two though isn't it i mean yeah but it's only two yeah name two more iconic historians. Holland and Sandbrook. Right. Okay, so I rest
霍兰（Holland）和桑德布鲁克（Sandbrook）。对。好吧，那我无话可说了。保罗·邓肯（Paul Duncan）问，你最喜欢的黄金时代是什么？嗯，我想我们都知道你的答案，不是吗？
my case. Paul Duncan says, what is your favourite golden age? Well, we think we know yours, don't we?
你最喜欢的黄金时代是荷兰共和国。确实是的。我只想站出来说，
Your favourite golden age is the Dutch Republic. It is. I just think that I'm going to stand up and
我认为荷兰的黄金时代就是一个黄金时代。纽约时报曾有一篇长文说那是，我认为说它已被取消是种族主义。我不在乎。我要冒着被“取消”的风险，站出来捍卫荷兰的黄金时代。有一个展览，我想是在加拿大，展出伦勃朗的作品。我想是伦勃朗，伦勃朗绘画的黄金时代。
say I think the Dutch golden age is a golden age. There was a big essay in the New York Times saying that it was, I think, racist to say that it's been cancelled. I don't care. I'm going to risk cancellation by standing up for the Dutch Golden Age. There's an exhibition, I think it's in Canada, of Rembrandt. I think it's Rembrandt, the Golden Age of Rembrandt paintings.
我在网上看到了这个。有人对此做了非常大的报道。当你走进每一个展厅时，几乎每一条图片说明——因为它们的说明非常像贾斯廷·特鲁多（Justin Trudeau）式的说明。所以每一条说明都在说，你知道的，伦勃朗画了这幅画，画的是某个荷兰市民或什么的。但只要想想，如果不是因为奴隶制，会有多少更多的伦勃朗作品从我们手中流失，
And I saw this online. Somebody's done a huge thing about it. Virtually every single caption when you go into every, because they're sort of very Justin Trudeau-like captions. So every single caption says, you know, Rembrandt painted this painting of some Dutch burger or something. But just think, if it hadn't been for slavery, how many more Rembrandts have been lost to us you know
潜在的伦勃朗。换句话说，你不能单纯地欣赏伦勃朗本身，你必须意识到伦勃朗世界的成本，意识到那些牺牲者以及所有这些。好吧，这没问题，但我认为——但我认为这必须被考虑在内。没有剥削就不可能有黄金时代。是的，我的意思是，这不像——因为那是怎么回事？是波茨劳德（Portslade）的史蒂夫（Steve）提出的关于这是一个道德时代的问题吗？我其实不这么认为。我认为这关乎权力、繁荣、文化成就的结合，以及一种人们能够回首过去而不会感到太多道德焦虑或政治焦虑的遗产。我完全接受这个事实，你知道的，我的意思是，黄金时代的荷兰人是原始资本主义者。我不认为我们看伦勃朗时会像我们看待国家名胜古迹信托基金（National Trust）的财产那样去思考奴隶制，也许吧。不管怎样，有些我们会这样想。你还没问我最喜欢的黄金时代呢。多米尼克，你最喜欢的黄金时代是什么？我不知道。我还在想。但你为什么让我问你呢？也许是1976年的英国
potential rembrandt so in other words you can't just appreciate rembrandt on his own you have to be conscious of the costs of rembrandt's world of the casualties all that stuff well that's fine i but but i think i think that has i mean i think that has to be factored in you cannot have a golden age without exploitation yeah i mean it's not like because what was it was it uh um yeah steve from portslade's question about it being a moral one i don't actually think it is i think it's about a mixture of power prosperity cultural achievement um and a kind of legacy that people can look back on without too much moral anxiety or political anxiety. And I entirely accept the fact, you know, I mean, the Dutch in the golden age are proto-capitalists. I mean't think that we look at Rembrandt and think about slavery in the way, say, that we might look at a national trust property, perhaps,
到1979年？说吧。不，我认为……亲爱的，你一定有一个，否则你不会让我问你的。我挺崇尚吉本风格的。我想可能是因为我读过……图拉真（Trajan）？也许是因为我读过……
and think about slavery. Well, some of us, anyway. You haven't asked me for my golden age. Dominic, what's your favourite golden age? I don't know. I'm still thinking about it. But why did you ask me to ask you? Maybe Britain 1976
是的，因为我在一个容易受影响的青少年时期读过它。对，exactly。图拉真统治下的罗马或什么的。但那也带有矛盾心理的阴影，不是吗？我想很大程度上是因为我把自己想象成那种躺在躺椅上吃葡萄的超级大胖子，而不是竞技场里的角斗士或什么的。但我绝对认为罗马作为某种黄金时代的这种感觉，深深植根于任何通过读《瓢虫书》（Ladybird books）长大、或者后来观看《角斗士》或诸如此类作品的人的想象中，难道不是吗？我的意思是，我认为
to 9? Go on. No, I think... Darling, you must have one or you wouldn't have asked me to ask you. I'm quite Gibbonian. I think maybe because I read... Trajan? Maybe because I read it... Yeah, because
对我来说，罗马就是那个，是的，但吉本式的描述充满了矛盾和讽刺。所以他谈到涅尔瓦（Nerva）、图拉真、哈德良（Hadrian）、安东尼（Antonines），他们以自由的形象为乐。那不是我。我以自由的形象为乐，而不是其实质。好吧，也对。我自诩为自由主义者。嗯，我不是。我自诩为自由主义者。嗯，我甚至不自诩为自由主义者。
I read it when I was a sort of impressionable teenager. Yeah, exactly. The Rome under Trajan or something. But that's shaded about by ambivalence, isn't it? I think it's largely because I picture myself as one of the sort of enormously fat men lying on a couch eating grapes rather than as a gladiator in the arena or something um but i absolutely think that that sense of rome being a kind of golden age is is um embedded in the imagination of anybody who grew up reading ladybug books or later on watching gladiator or any of those kinds of things don't you i mean i think
我自诩为一个热爱自由的人，但实际上我是个独裁者。你是吗？是的，我其实挺独裁的。好吧，就在这个重磅炸弹抛出之际，自称独裁者得多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。好吧，是的，这与整个马克思主义历史学家的调性不谋而合，对吧，是的，你知道的，我可能是齐奥塞斯库（Ceausescu）……好啦，我们只是在闲聊，我们已经有一段时间没这么做了，因为之前我们都在做一些关于水门事件之类高度专注的节目。在开始录制之前我就在想，我们已经很久没有做过这种非常随性、漫无边际、
to me rome is the yeah but but so is is the epitome, actually. But that Gibbonian description is so shaded by ambivalence and irony. So he's talking about Nerva, Trajan, Hadrian, the Antonines, who delighted in the image of liberty. That's not me. I delighted in the image of liberty, but not the substance. Well, fair enough. I pose as a libertarian. Well, I don. I pose as a libertarian. Well, I don't even pose as a libertarian.
废话连篇的节目了。总之，顺着这个话题，你还有什么理智的话要说吗？对，我们接下来其实有一个非常棒的播客，是关于中世纪科学的。是的，我们有。
I pose as a freedom-loving person, but actually I'm an autocrat. Are you? Yeah, I'm quite autocratic, actually. Well, on that bombshell, self-avowed autocrat Dominic Sandbrook. Well, yeah, it goes hand in hand with the whole Marxistist with the whole marxist historian thing right yes you know i could be ceausescu um right we're just generating we haven't done that for a while because we've been doing some quite focused episodes on watergate and stuff before we start this i thought we haven't done a really vague rambling. Dribble.
那是科学的黄金时代吗？是的，我想大家会非常喜欢，因为它会更加聚焦，里面会有真正的干货，而且我们还请了一位嘉宾，所以就是这样，嗯，希望我们下次再见，再见。如果我们还没把你彻底吓跑的话，再见啦，谢谢收听《历史的剩余》（The Rest Is History）。
Dribble filled one. Anyway, on that note, do you have anything else sensible to say? Yeah, we've got a very good podcast coming up actually about medieval science. Yes, we do. Which I think everybody will.
想要获取独家单集、抢先收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
Was it the golden age of science? Yeah, which I think people will really enjoy because it will be much more focused and there'll be proper facts in it and we've got a guest so that's something um so we shall see you hopefully um next time goodbye if we haven't put you off for good bye-bye thanks for listening to The Rest Is History.
那是科学的黄金时代吗？是的，我认为大家会非常喜欢，因为它会更有针对性，里面会有真正的科学事实，我们还请了一位嘉宾，所以就是这样，嗯，希望我们下次再见，再见，如果我们还没有彻底把你们吓跑的话，再见，感谢收听《历史的余烬》。
For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如需收听加更节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。